[Musica]
c'è un tempo per nascere
c'è un tempo per morire c'è un tempo per
amare
c'è un tempo per tirare sassi c'è un
tempo per arrabbiarsi un tempo per
riconciliarsi un tempo per fare l'amore
è un tempo per separarsi e queste parole
sono state cantate molto tempo fa circa
2500 anni fa con una cetra che si
accordava con i sette corde così veniva
chiamata la cifra la città di quel et e
ognuna di queste corde corde di minuti
avrebbe dovuto accordarsi con gli astri
e con i pianeti perché il tempo che noi
viviamo è un tempo interno che si milla
nell'umano e diventa ovviamente il tempo
del cosmo quelle la sapienza ed è sempre
stato un grande problema quello di
poterlo definire l'uomo l'ha sempre
inseguito da sempre ricercato da sempre
avviato io oggi sono un poco qui come il
bianconiglio di alice no un orologio in
tasca che in qualche maniera segna il
mio del nostro tempo
il tempo è un ritmo lo abbiamo appreso
quando ancora nell'acqua delle origini
nel grembo di nostra madre
sentivamo il battito il battito del suo
cuore il battito del nostro cuore e gli
antichi latini hanno quasi inventato
tutto loro spugna di quella che è stata
la grande civiltà del mediterraneo ma
ovviamente una ambiente estremamente
poroso di molte sollecitazioni l'hanno
trasformato nel ritmo dell'esame tron
l'esame through era il modo per riuscire
a cantare
questo battito è il verso dell'epica ma
sotto il verso dell'epica nelle
straordinarie curve delle carte dei
manoscritti si nasconde proprio questa
musica che antica che antichissima la
sentite e dentro di voi in questo
momento il cuore può battere più forte
meno forte ma è sempre quella da
trattata ta ta ta ta ta quadro pedante
put renzoni tu ti pungola campo e che
cos'è il tempo di una cavalcata una
cavalcata folle spaventosa una
straordinaria avanzata di cavalieri che
lungo la piana di [ __ ] si spostano in
velocità gridando e facendo battere il
suono di quattro zoccoli sopra un
territorio putrido cosiddetto in
italiano è orribile ma il 4 pedante
potrebbe subito un patito gula campo
aumenta ancora di più il ritmo e la
ritmo si fa frenesia e la frenesia si fa
canto d'amore bene la notte forse più
bella della letteratura latina la notte
raccontata da ovidio nei tristi a video
deve partire per andarsene via per
volere dell'imperatore che gli contesta
il fatto che lui abbia visto qualcosa
che non doveva vedere in questa ultima
notte passata tra le braccia della donna
che ama
e qual è il tempo meglio speso o video
sciogliendosi nei capelli di lei canta
il battito del tempo che passa e ogni
brano di polvere che scende lento nella
clessidra diventa un sussurro d'amore
cantato ma per l'eternità
perché diventa eterno len dell'ente
currite noctis è quest corrette piano ma
piano cavalli della notte perché se la
notte passa tra un pò veloce se l'alpe
giare arriva troppo presto
io devo sussurrarti mio dolce amore
l'addio della mia esistenza
e questo non arrivi mai piede e mano
battuta s'inganna la morte nella danza è
il tamburello il cembalo e gli sciamani
pulsano ripetendo il suono antico
dell'esame throw se fate attenzione se
fossimo in un tempo straniato se fossimo
in un altro luogo ma poco lontano da qui
nelle colline della morena friulana e
fossimo intorno al 1500 e 68.570 un
musico negromante e mago che noi ben
conosciamo ed è ma in aereo il grande
maestro di cappella dei patriarchi di
aquileia che qui aleggiano ancora in un
tempo sospeso quasi lo avvertiamo
inseguendo la zampogna la la cornamusa
con piede pulsato con battito di piede
pulsato andavano alla ricerca di quella
sistole e diastole di quel pendolo che
fa incantare la luna e che come facevamo
le streghe slovene della stessa epoca
poteva in qualche modo fermarsi lungo la
strana corona dei monti o delle colline
e bloccarsi lì per un momento incantare
significa cantare dentro il senso delle
cose e bloccare per un attimo soltanto
che però può durare quanto un'eternità
il fluire del senso del tempo o per lo
meno della sua memoria ferma il tempo e
inganni la morte che ovviamente nella
danza attende invano è tutto lì nel
tempo dell'essere è il sottile
equilibrio che passa tra eros l'amore
l'energia l'energia
abbiamo sentito parlare prima di tempo e
di cosmo e thanatos la morte dei libri
delle ore del medioevo la morte appare
con una sottile corona d'argento e
ricorda non per fare paura che lei si
presenterà alla fine della nostra
esistenza ma non per punirci si
presenterà per chiederci se il nostro
tempo è stato un tempo bene speso se il
tempo che abbiamo dedicato alla nostra
vita è stato un tempo pieno di cose di
incontri un distillato di ebbrezza
questo ci chiederà quell'oscura signora
ed è tutto lì nella magnificenza di uno
spazio che diventa anche tempo vedete
come il linguaggio della fisica teorica
si abbraccia così da vicino con il
linguaggio dell'arte della poesia
dell'antropologia e della filosofia è
quello spazio quel tempo invischiato in
un dito che crea in un dito che viene
creato in un senso di humanitas e a che
vedere con un fumus ma anche con mano il
nostro pollice opponibile è quello che
ci fa percepire forse per la prima volta
nell'essere creatori o sub creatori nel
modellare le forme e significati che noi
possiamo avere il nostro tempo tra le
mani e in quella scintilla lì
di michelangelo in quella da mo che
addormentato sogna e sogna perché ancora
non vive e non vive ancora perché non ha
il senso del tempo che è tuttora chiuso
invece nel mistero dell'inizio e prima
di adamo chi c'è dopo adamo
chi ci sarà adamo l'uomo che da i nomi
alle cose che ruba l'anima al mondo e
che si fa lui stesso granello di tempo e
granello di polvere nel senso delle cose
e questa è forse la mia preferita è la
mia preferita perché in questo bacio che
viene esemplato in uno stile
meraviglioso la scalata pittura
vascolare greca del della prima polis
siamo nell'ottavo secolo avanti cristo
in questo vaso c'è un bacio che dura da
più di duemila anni
e dura da più di duemila anni 2.800 anni
perché non è mai stato dato il tempo di
quel bacio diventa un tempo di eternità
condivisa esattamente come il dito di
dio che discende dall infinito e
trasforma l'infinito in presente e gli
dà il senso e la forza dell'essere bello
qui e ora lo canta il grandissimo poeta
kit nella famosa odd one grecia torna
lode su di un urna greca e luna greca
proprio questa ma in che cosa consiste
quel tempo sospeso io sono certo che
tutti abbiate assaporato l'essenza di
quel tempo che precede il bacio
perché lì che il respiro diventa alito e
l'alito diventa anemos vento e il vento
diventa spirito è lo spirito si mescola
e si fa tiepido vapore e il tiepido
vapore diventa emozione e l'emozione va
condivisa ma va distillata piano come
diceva il buon rostan
l'app è che sfugge la dolcezza del miele
dalla corolla del fiore ma prima ancora
che questo accade è lì tutta la dolcezza
del miele in un bacio non dato che
durerà nell'infinito corso del tempo che
durerà per sempre
e allora orazio ispirandosi ad uno stile
del genere in una notte d'inverno quando
il tempo sembra non finire mai dice alla
sua bella nel cono e dai lunghi capelli
neri scioglieteli show litri per me
adesso in questo momento lascia che i
sogni ti rimangano appesi sotto le
ciglia proprio qui sotto nel bordeaux
estremo dell'occhio
non ti preoccupare mai del tempo che
zeus avrebbe concesso non chiederti
quanti inverni ancora a faticheranno le
onde rabbiosa dell'adriatico questo
questo istante che precede i nostri baci
sia il nostro tempo per l'eternità nesci
generosa la coppa al vino sabino e poi
scambiamo cielo assieme ad un amore che
durante la notte intera potrà durare
sostanzialmente per sempre
e john dowland il grandissimo autore
dell'età elisabettiana in questa sua
dimensione della musica che ripete il
senso di quel et e della cetra ebraica
in una architettura musicale che parla
di vita e parla d'amore e parla di
istanti e parla di fugazi a attimi e di
sensazioni e di curiose preoccupazioni
canta arabe scando sul suo partito una
meraviglia che è ancora una volta
l'incanto di una musica e il camec and
came gann sui club torna ancora torna
ancora da me amore dolce e amore gentile
fa che questa mia notte sia una notte
non piena di sonno ma se una notte piena
di sogni e che cosa siamo noi
gli fa eco il suo forse più noto
conterraneo sono un condensato di sogni
un impasto di cui è intessuta la nostra
vita
un sogno può sembrarci lungo quanto una
vita lungo quanto un tempo indefinito e
la vita può essere breve e dolce come
soltanto un sogno può essere el'attesa è
l'attesa che ci permette di trasformare
la memoria in volontà che ci permette di
dare un senso ed un significato alle
cose che noi assaggiamo l'intera
letteratura e l'intera filosofia giocano
sul senso dell'aspettare e aspettare non
significa perdere il tempo ma significa
avere l'opportunità di assaporarlo fino
in fondo noi oggi non abbiamo più tempo
corriamo in questo mobile ordigno di
dentate ruote che macina il tempo e lo
riduce in ore ciro di pers
il nostro ciro di pers probabilmente è
stato anche qui a cantare il suo tempo
abbiamo paura di attendere le nostre
sale d'attesa sono una penosa miseria
abbiamo trasformato la nostra vita
nell'attendere qualche cosa che non
arriverà mai
nel trasformare il nostro presente in un
nulla né l'idea che il futuro che
ovviamente non esiste ancora il passato
che non esiste più non acquistano
significato se non in questo debole
nostro essere qui adesso che trasforma
velocemente il futuro e in passato
attraverso il senso della memoria
noi recuperiamo davvero chi siamo che
vogliamo essere e soprattutto come lo
vogliamo essere
ed è questo il lampo del mito è il lampo
del rito nella coeva dell'asma nus nel
messico
questo uomo del 12 mila avanti cristo ha
lasciato il segno del tempo attorno al
colore della sua mano le brezza e ve lo
consentono di fare è appoggiare la
vostra mano su quella mano vi apre una
sorta di fascinazione spazio temporale
per cui 12.000 anni si riassumono nel
contatto di un'ombra l'ombra di quella
mano che ci ricorda una cosa importante
che noi siamo come lui era esseri umani
e abbiamo bisogno di passione
abbiamo bisogno di sentire forte
attraverso il tempo
la dimensione che è solo nostra perché
noi lo percepiamo ci sono alberi che
hanno 10.000 anni è una cosa
impressionante con foglie che crescono a
distanza di centinaia di anni le une
dalle altre ma non hanno memoria di se
stessi
io appoggiando la mia mano su questa
mano
ho avvertito che 12.000 anni sono
soltanto un momento sono soltanto un
battito un istante e allora ci chiediamo
come cantava il salmista sentinella a
che punto è arrivata la notte fino a che
punto fino a quando noi dobbiamo
attendere ed aspettare
impariamo ad assaporarla la notte
impariamo a immaginare di ascoltare nel
buio che ci circonda il suono dei
filamenti dell'erba che crescono il
ronzio che fanno le stelle quando
passano nell'alto dei cieli e che forse
è un nostro ronzio interiore lo
scricchiolio dello scranno nel quale
siamo seduti e non stanchiamoci di
chiedere mai sentinella a che punto è
arrivata la notte perché prima o poi
questa verrà palesata da un debole
biancore che compare ad oriente e che ci
dice che forse il tempo per noi è
arrivato ma attenzione anche il mio
ormai è fuggito perché il tempo e questo
è il kairos è rappresentato così dagli
antichi è un attimo fugace ci rimane
sempre alle spalle ci sorpassa quando
vuole
non ce ne rendiamo conto ma a un ciuffo
un ciuffo lungo che gli cadde sulla
fronte e li dobbiamo essere attenti a
acciuffarlo a prenderlo nel momento in
cui passa accoglierlo ea non farci
trovare impreparati
kairos lo trovate sulla costa della
dalmazia a troverà perfettamente
rappresentato lì esattamente come
duemila anni fa cogliere quell'istante
cogliere quel momento acciuffare
l'attimo significa
pensare che la nostra vita sia piena di
tempo
nel senso che deve mantenere la pienezza
del tempo
seneca non sperate di aggiungere anni
alla vostra vita ma auspicate di
aggiungere vita ai vostri anni potrai
raggiungere un'età di ultracentenario e
non aver vissuto neanche un istante
potrei vivere 30 anni dieci anni un mese
un'ora soltanto
e quel tempo sarà un tempo intatto e
meraviglioso che ti dà il senso della
meraviglia
e allora come il grande faust guardando
l'infinita del cielo dopo aver fatto il
patto con il nostro demonio personale e
ciascuno di noi ha un demone con il
quale scende a patti arrampichiamoci
sull'ultima è più alta puglia del
pinnacolo del nostro castello e vedendo
che il biancore dell'alba sta arrivando
e ci dice che il nostro tempo è finito
possiamo anche noi dirgli attimo
fuggente fermati perché sei bello grazie
[Applauso]